and my voice is the same way she you
know had a a not a
great you know family environment in in
some regards and so she's so like
i just want to keep it a hundred and
positive as much as possible really but
but same thing like we both uh you know
life gets you into a
a dark uh time it
but we just um we're good about like
picking each other up and and being like
yo count the count the blessings versus
what you don't have which is what this
business you can probably attest to that
uh as well where you're like
when can you adjust your mind to like
to to really think what's going on what
have i stacked on in the last couple
years versus what have i not
achieved and it's such an easier said
than done way of thinking but but being
insatiable is not always good yeah it's
not good at all i think if you're always
expecting like i i i need more i gotta
have more i gotta and you realize but
that's not making you happy and it
hasn't made you happy success hasn't
made me happy it's been a temporary
happy it's more uh you know i always say
it's like the colander you know it's
like you know it just goes right through
like you know water goes right through
the column yeah it's like it's ephemeral
it lasts
minutes yeah you're like oh my god i'm
great i'm really great
okay wait when can i be great again i've
got to prove myself again i've got to do
this again and then you guys you're like
what am i chasing
and i i you know for me i think it's
like you know hey love
love memories relationships connections
those are the most important things in
the world
and uh
so that's what you know i'm working on
that more but like you know it's you
know for somebody who i didn't have it
growing up when i was going through
the it factor well i was you know
dysfunctional family like many people
i've talked about it but like i didn't i
didn't feel loved i didn't feel like i
you know uh and so i looked for it
elsewhere and all of a sudden i was the
funny guy and i was like oh i'll make
everybody laugh yeah and then you know i
my friends would their parents would be
my surrogate parents yeah you know i
would make them laugh and i'd stay weeks
over their house wow um and then i was
the funny guy and i think at that point
as a small boy i realized you're gonna
be accepted if you're funny if you're
just being the funny guy and don't be
your boring stupid ignorant self that's
how i thought and i went through that
for years until through all my success
make people laugh be good be on you're
great you're great and eventually you
just go
wow i'm [ __ ] tired yeah and i don't
know who the [ __ ] i am yeah and that
just gets old and you gotta i don't want
to be 90 and go
what was i doing it for was that who was
i doing this [ __ ] [ __ ] for that's a
good impression of you at 90 by the way
i i don't think i'll be alive at night i
think he will you think so yeah and that
voice sounds like a guy that takes care
of himself because 90 90 should be a
little bit more like that i don't know
my grandfather he was 92 when he passed
away and he was like mike you know you
shouldn't fart all the time great
shouldn't fart yeah i always fart
he doesn't like that you fart well he'd
say you know you're gonna do that you're
not gonna know you did it
awesome but then i'll be like right your
t-shirt this face on it you're going to
do it and not know you did it farts what
did i do whoever smelled it delta yeah
exactly uh yeah that
man okay well you're
preaching to the choir because yeah i
think me with this full head of steam of
like let's just [ __ ] push it down
worry about it later make people happy
feel good that's a better easier more
fun path
yeah and then
but to my detriment it probably
uh
you know
it's uh allowed me
to uh not figure out who i am on and off
stage quicker right right because i was
like well let's not
be that guy that you are let's be
but also again but you're on the flip
side i feel like i'm
i am who i am because of all that [ __ ]
right because of like the the the being
uh bullied and and the folks thing and
and seeing my mom and dad's like just
how tumultuous that was
and uh and wanting to be on top of that
and just have a a glass-half-full
approach i am who i am because of all
that so i can't there's no part of me
that really wants to
that would say
would i be this if they [ __ ] figured
it out and kept their marriage together
and stayed in love right probably not